schule haben melina und laila seit
monaten nicht digital unterricht
fehlanzeige stattdessen gibt es über
gerd der 80 jährige ehemalige elektriker
lernt mit seinen enkelinnen jeden tag
die versuche sich zu erklären und ich
immer gelingt ein das wie es nötig ist
nicht wahr ist das alles bei nacht ein
die man weit verändern oder richtig
machen greifen und jetzt bleiben von der
sechster auf julius von der 10 4
abgezogen als kommen da raus
seit monaten wohnen die beiden
schwestern bei opa ihre mama ist selbst
in einer ausbildung eine kleine
schwester gibt es auch noch und zu hause
ist nur wenig platz
lernen in einer ausnahmesituation wirtin
wird nötigste vermittelt wenn sie hunger
und kriegen gerade mal so ein brocken
hingeschmissen der zeitung gefühl so ein
bisschen reduzieren können ja so sind
ihre mittel ihm lernen auch der lehrer
oder die lehrerin könnte die ganz anders
vermitteln
morgens in der berliner arche kinder die
zum lernen kommen die christliche
stiftung kümmert sich um benachteiligte
familien und zeigt dass unterricht auch
in einer pandemie nicht ausfallen muss
man hat sich keine gedanken darüber
gemacht dass es eben auch eine
bildungsferne schichten gibt dass kinder
auch bei menschen aufwachsen die
vielleicht überaltert sind weil der und
die oma oder der opa sozusagen sich
darum kümmern müssen
das hat natürlich zufolge es hat sich
keiner gedanken gemacht also gibt es
verlierer
viele der kinder haben von ihren lehrern
wochenlang nichts oder nur wenig gehört
es ist dann eine frage mit 600 laptops
hat pfarrer bernd siggelkow für die
kinder besorgt damit sie homeschooling
machen können doch von den schulen käme
viel zu wenig unterstützung
man hat schon nach den sommerferien
gemerkt als die kinder wieder in die
schule gegangen sind wie viel defizit
diese haben und jetzt sind diese
defizite so groß es sind jetzt gerade
erstklässler im august und september in
die schule gekommen
die gar keinen präsenzunterricht hatten
die lernen jetzt zu hause was man so
lernen kann sie lernen ja kein system
jetzt ist das chaos groß denn ich also
ich nenne es alles homeschooling chaos
weil kein herz mehr im griff selbst die
mittelschicht eltern sagen ich kann ich
mir das infozentrum für bildungsökonomie
in münchen leiter ludger wößmann hat
errechnet dass die lernzeit der kinder
sich von täglich 7 auf dreieinhalb
stunden halbiert hat wir sehen in
unserer befragung für deutschland dass
die lernzeit erstaunlicherweise bei
akademiker kindern genauso stark zurück
gegangen ist wie bei nicht
akademikerkindern also es ist auch nicht
so dass jetzt die bildungsnahen
schichten das komplett schaffen dass die
kinder jetzt zu hause viel lernen
verheerend sei das weniger bildung
bedeutet später weniger verdienst der
schaden für die volkswirtschaft sei groß
ein politikversagen wir hatten die
biergärten die baumärkte längst wieder
geöffnet als wir noch darüber
diskutieren waren welche konzepte wir
denn für die schulen hätten zum öffnen
und langfristig werden diese kosten viel
höher sein wenn wir es nicht schaffen
den kindern sozusagen das zu vermitteln
was sie ihm vermittelt werden muss aber
es sind auch die psychischen folgen
maria will dieses jahr abitur machen
nach einem jahr beinahe stillstand
die erste zeit war es so ich bin
aufgestanden und ich wusste gar nicht
wohin mit mir ich habe auch sehr
schlecht geschlafen immer sehr lange
dann war der tag schon fast vorbei jetzt
im winter ist es ja auch schnell wieder
dunkel dann war man halt überhaupt nicht
motiviert sich fern der schule einen
geregelten tagesablauf zu schaffen hat
gedauert jeden morgen macht sie nun yoga
dann geht es an das selbstbestimmte
lernen
jetzt wird ja das kinderzimmer oder das
wohnzimmer zum klassenzimmer und das
muss man sich natürlich wie ein bisschen
drauf vorbereiten weil sonst sitzt man
da und starrt ins leere und schafft
nichts und die lehrer
manche seien regelrecht abgetaucht
andere sehr engagiert doch an den
problemen der schüler nur wenig
interessiert
wir fragen uns jetzt nicht habt ihr
angst um ihre zukunft habt ja auch zum
abitur wie stellt ihr euch das vorder
habt ihr was das angeht fragen bist
irgend seid ihr aufgeschlossen bis nach
dem habe ich für euch weitergeht was
haltet ihr für pläne wie sehen die kraft
aus also wir werden da so gar nicht
abgeholten das fiel mir persönlich damit
kommen immer mehr schüler und
schülerinnen nicht klar
hier in der münchner uniklinik melden
sich zunehmend verzweifelte eltern geht
schulte körne und seine kinder und
jugendpsychiatrie arbeiten längst am
limit
wer jetzt im zweiten lockdown geht es
wahnsinnig zu also muss wirklich sagen
hat so viele anfragen auch nach
stationärer behandlung des haben wir
lange nicht mehr erlebt und die
kapazitäten sind begrenzt und wir müssen
da hat wir können auch jetzt wirklich
nur noch die schwerstkranken versorgen
seit kurzem versucht gerd schulte körne
mit der webpage corona und die erste
hilfe zu leisten
vor allem die monate lange isolation zu
hause sei für viele der probleme
verantwortlich
bei den jüngeren kindern sehen wir schon
mehr so angst probleme und
verhaltensprobleme während wir bei den
jugendlichen jetzt die depression
vorgesehen und auch zunimmt essstörungen
wir hatten nach dem ersten locker und
kinder die haben zehn bis zwanzig kilo
zugenommen
die konnten sich nicht mehr bewegen die
haben kein sportunterricht gemacht die
waren nicht draußen gewesen
und so geht es den kindern lernen für
den mittleren schulabschluss hier in der
arche werden die kinder motiviert nicht
aufzugeben auch ohne schule
weiterzumachen
das versäumnis der bundesregierung oder
beziehungsweise der kultusminister ist
nicht mehr gut zu machen
also man hat elf monate fans das heißt
man hat eine gang ein ganzes schuljahr
ein ganzes schuljahr verschenkt das gilt
ja nicht nur für die erstklässler
das gilt für die abschlussklassen das
gilt für die weiterführenden klassen das
gilt ja für alle schüler die 19 jährige
maria hat sich selbst organisiert lernt
täglich mit ihrem freund leo das abi
werden wir schon schaffen sagen die
beiden
aber dann wie wird es weitergehen wir
sind die zukunft später wir sind dafür
verantwortlich
die welt weiter so weit wie sie es sie
zu verbessern und das können wir nur
wenn ein gewisser bildungsstand
gewährleistet wird
und der wird gerade nicht gewährleistet
und die folgen davon während sich später
noch äußern das kann man jetzt noch gar
nicht einschätzen
unternehmen die verantwortlichen
politiker wirklich alles dafür dass
kinder auch in diesen zeiten lernen
können
das monatelange schließen der schulen
hat folgen es braucht lösungen damit das
recht auf bildung endlich wieder
hergestellt ist
[Musik]
[Gelächter]